ah eat up here look at my little baby
boy hi guys this is Maddy if you're new
here you've probably already seen them
even if you are new he is the love of my
life he is the sweetest little soul and
he is also I am extremely excited to
announce that he did win for the world
dog Awards my new puppy so basically
this right here this is our puppy of the
year can you believe it Maddy can you
believe it
we recently went to the dog Awards if
you guys remember in some of my
snapchats and my Instagram posts I was
asking you guys to vote for Matty and
guess what you want you guys can watch
the world dog award Tucson the CW and
it's on Thursday January 14th so
depending upon when I post this video it
might be tonight it might be already
over but I'm sure you can find it
somewhere on the Internet well what this
video is actually about is we now know
what Maddie is we took a DNA test my dad
did it while I was home for Christmas
and you take this little swab and you
swab the inside of their mouth and you
put it in this little kit and you send
it off to the lab and then they will
tell you what your dog is there are
several different ones my sister did the
wisdom panel 2.0 I did the 2.5 and
there's also the wisdom panel 3.0 which
will tell you if your dog has some sort
of crossbreed with a wolf so I didn't
think that we had anything to worry
about with this little guy because I
don't think he's a wolf
but what he is is not what I thought he
was and when I got him
the rescue told me that they thought
that he was a poodle Maltese such as a
Maltipoo so that's what I've been
telling people but everyone on the
internet seems to think differently
don't go down there hey come here what I
need to get him something so that helped
like me again whoa whoa whoa whoa are we
gonna tell them what you are now well we
can you tell them what you are you are
is a mixed pup for sure those great
grandparents are two miniature poodles
mixed with two chihuahuas and then the
grandparents are miniature poodle
Chihuahua which makes his parents
miniature poodle cross Chihuahua so on
the other side his family his great
grandparents are miniature poodle Lhasa
Apso is a
Brown said I'm mature he's on with a
mixed-breed so we have no idea what that
Bijan was getting into and then we got
his grandparents the miniature poodle
and the abyssal cross with the Bijan mix
you're a mess but you're a cute little
mess so I guess all in all he's a
miniature poodle Chihuahua Bijan and
Lhasa Apso mix that's what you are
sit catch oh you're so smart so guys
that's what Maddie is I can't believe
he's part Chihuahua I actually never
would have thought I mean I didn't think
he was a Maltese because he has
absolutely judging by this DNA test
no Maltese at all in your little body
none at all
can't you look at it oh good have you
been following me for a while I think
one of the things that I've always said
that I wanted was a dog but I knew that
it would be probably one of the most
difficult things ever and I don't think
I actually ever realized how difficult
it would be because this little guy has
been such a challenge especially with
traveling a lot and trying to actually
get work done and then when we first got
him he had all kinds of allergies so I
spent so much time and money at the vet
but guess what he's doing well and now
that he's almost out of his little crazy
puppy stage I've got one of the most
lovely and fantastic little human
puppies ever catch it thank you guys so
much for being so supportive of Maddie
if he has gonna follow him on Instagram
it's DJ mini Matt it's also DJ mini Matt
on Twitter and I'm really excited cuz ah
we've got some fun things in store with
him and with you guys this year so stay
tuned because it's gonna be really
really fun wheels on safe to say move on
see how fun it's gonna be Maddie tome
will drop board hello
he's so crazy hi say bye Mary say
goodbye are you hungry
who's here oh I love you more than the
vision with the big last high-five
people of you wouldn't even give me a
single high-five you embarrass me for
all my friends is it because I don't
have any treats
guess that's why huh alright guys got my
outfit is so one point this is actually
a trackpad now so this allows you to
have more control over your Apple TV and
you can sort of treat it like a trackpad